По всій Німеччині з’являються нові вітряні електростанції. Це справжні
технологічні шедеври - більші, ніж найвищі у світі церковні вежі.
Чим більші, тим потужніші. Довгострокова мета Німеччини -
відмова від вугілля і перехід на відновлювальні джерела енергії,
зокрема енергію вітру.
Внизу на будівельному майданчику робітники збирають докупи сегменти вітряка.
Масивна основа вежі ​з бетону - єдиний спосіб закріпити такі височенні вежі.
Ми почали з першого прототипу в 2010 році.
З того часу ми побудували та звели понад 2000 вітряних генераторів.
Серед іншого - і найвищу у світі установку в 2017 році - з висотою хабу 178 метрів
і лопатями понад 240 метрів.
Тринадцять вітряних турбін будуються нині на заході Німеччини поблизу Мюнстера.
Вони мають додатково постачати енергію. Особливо після того, як останню вугільну
електростанцію у Німеччині виведуть з експлуатації в 2038 році.
Але розбудова вітрових парків у багатьох регіонах країни відбувається
недостатньо швидко, нарікає Мілан Нітцшке. Він керує компанією,
яка експлуатує цю вітряну електростанцію.
Цей проєкт особливий. Від самого початку він здобув потужну підтримку
з боку місцевої влади, району та місцевого населення.
У ньому беруть участь навіть комунальні підприємства міста, тому все робиться
набагато швидше. Але там, де місцеві кажуть: "Не на моєму подвір’ї",
це може тривати набагато більше часу.
Такі банери демонструють спротив місцевого населення. Мешканці нарікають,
що вітряні турбіни спотворюють ландшафт. Тому іноді схвалення таких
проєктів може затягнутися і на десять років, поки їх затвердять.
Приміром, у цьому селі чимало активних мешканців. Мехтільд Арнінґ дратує,
що її будинок оточений вітряками.
Тепер їх має стати ще більше - менш ніж за кілометр від її подвір'я.
Шум від обертання вітрових турбін можна почути за півтора кілометра.
Тобто вже це одне дратує. І якщо збудують ще більше і ближче вітряків,
то у сонячний постійно буде мерехтлива тінь.
Але конфлікти можна вирішувати у кращий спосіб - приміром, залучити
громади до співпраці. Мілан Нітцшке заздалегідь поспілкувався з місцевими жителями
та запропонував їм частку від прибутку цієї вітроелектростанції.
Ми збираємо приватні інвестиції у проєкт від місцевих жителів.
Вони, по суті, дають нам позику, а ми повертаємо їм відсотки за фіксованою ставкою.
Це може бути п’ять відсотків, може, шість. Це доволі багато порівняно
з процентними ставками, які сьогодні пропонують банки.
Ми запитали деяких мешканців, як вони ставляться до вітряної електростанції.
Вони мені не заважають, там, де я живу, їх немає, я бачу їх лише вдалині.
Мене це не дратує. Я думаю, що це добре,
тому що відновлювана енергія має звідкись надходити.
Звісно, я розумію природоохоронців, коли вони кажуть, що це негативно впливає
на навколишнє середовище. Я сама працюю на екологічній роботі,
тому цілком розумію їхні аргументи. Але гадаю, також добре,
що ми рухаємося в напрямку відновлюваної енергії
і поступово попрощаємося із застарілим викопним паливом.
Йоганнес Петер - місцевий фермер. Він віддав в оренду вітропарку
одне зі своїх угідь. А також придбав акції компанії й отримує річні дивіденди.
Сприйняття на місцях поліпшується,
коли залучені місцеві жителі. Вони беруть участь у проєкті й кажуть: це наш проєкт,
і він вигідний нам усім. Нам потрібна відновлювана енергія.
Ми отримаємо вигоду від проєкту, як тільки вітрогенератори запрацюють.
І коли серед контактних осіб - місцеві, це також однозначно
сприяє суспільному сприйняттю та розумінню.
Якби всі старі вітропарки в Німеччині замінили на ефективні,
подібні цим, країна могла б задовольнити нині всі свої поточні потреби в електроенергії.
Але в перспективі цього не вистачить. Потреби Німеччини в електроенергії
незабаром можуть подвоїтися - особливо, якщо електромобілі замінять
бензинові та дизельні. Тож, будівництво таких вітряних електростанцій зовсім не зайве.
Величезні лопаті та більшість компонентів доставляють такі гігантські вантажівки.
Їх супроводжують спеціальні машини.
Максимальна швидкість колони - 80 кілометрів на годину.
Керувати вантажем 80 метрів завдовжки на поворотах - складна операція.
Команда з 12 робітників стежить за тим, щоб все пройшло гладко.
Цю лопать виготовили у Польщі. Вона вже здолала тисячу кілометрів.
Роторні лопаті стають дедалі більшими.
Це завжди було великим викликом.
Спочатку ми сказали: нам доведеться зупинитися на 45 метрах.
Потім ми думали, що доведеться зупинитися на 50 метрах.
А тепер у нас лопаті довжиною понад 80 метрів.
Лопаті вітряка - це технологічний шедевр, й інженери працюють над тим,
щоб робити їх ще більш ефективними. Вони також намагаються зробити
турбіни більш екологічними та менш шкідливими для людей та тварин поблизу.
Щоб зробити турбіни тихішими,
ми використовуємо те, що ми називаємо "динозаврами" на лопатях,
тобто планки, які допомагають зменшити турбулентність і шум.
Щоб захистити навколишнє середовище, ми маємо реєстратори кажанів,
які вимикають турбіни, коли фіксують кажанів неподалік.
І в нас є датчики тіней. Тому, коли сонце світить
під певним кутом, сусіднім будівлям не заважають мерехтливі тіні.
Лопать мають ще до заходу сонця встановити на вежу.
Коли вітровий парк добудуть за кілька місяців, він забезпечить
зеленою енергією 40 тисяч домогосподарств.
Але нові вітроелектростанції матимуть успіх лише тоді,
коли люди, які мешкають поруч, дадуть їм зелене світло.
Тут, принаймні, знайшовся рецепт, щоб це функціонувало.